I'm going to stop with the question for
everybody in the film Steve Rogers keeps
a a checklist of all the great pop
culture stuff he's missed out on in the
last 50 years so if you had to recommend
anything for Steve what would it be and
why and let's start with you Anthony
work our way down to the other ethnic
mmm oh man why you so yeah okay I would
say you're done let me go yeah what oh
yeah we got unlucky too many ways about
you
oh yeah no he said over there I always
knew it please Oh Tony
after you uh I think I would I would ask
I would I would recommend that he check
out Captain America the Winter Soldier
yeah it took it tickles the absurdist in
me and I want to know did we get it
right does it does it feel
representative of your experience for
him of you a documentary I guess I'm Joe
uh four words fifty shades of gray
I think he needs more mommy porn in his
life the whole trilogy or just the first
one just the first one that's just the
first I I would stick with music I'd
probably do Beatles Led Zeppelin okay
interesting scarlet mmm cake pops how do
they make those things anyway they're
just so delicious and Samuel are red to
red
we might have just lost Captain America
than that one and sebast evade to the
Godfather for sure I mean right
Godfather maybe cronuts I don't know um
any Eddie Murphy movie before the golden
JA golden child I guess had anything
before that is like is that including
the golden child you want include that
in your no no God no job is included
okay okay good I won't the knife so the
golden child cronuts and cake pops were
fattening Captain America up okay that's
a take some questions just gentleman
over here and then we'll we'll try and
get everyone in due course I really
enjoyed the film I want to ask a
question basically you guys have had
such great and diverse careers if you
could take any one of the characters
that you played and put them in the
Marvel Universe which would you pick and
why don't want I can take any character
and play it and put it in the Marvel
Universe yes it had to fit it just so he
wouldn't put it in there oh my movies
are terrible I don't want to do anyone
else won't take the 15 yeah I pick Mitch
Hennessy from the law kiss good night in
the Marvel Universe
just because he's just so childlike and
would be in awe of everybody in there
but he would claim me at a superpower a
Scarlett go to UNIX on this any
character from your past you kidding a
Marvel Universe movie well if I could do
the voice from her would avoid the early
morning Jim hour so I'm gonna choose
that one usurping Jarvis maybe and
Sebastian and I yeah well looking at my
brilliant filmography outside of the
Captain America movies I'm just I'm
gonna speak right pour myself a glass of
water and mr. Mackie um I would say Nate
Ruffin Rudy from the main booty from the
main Stila work on the bottom after
devaki once again making Sam Jackson
I would say uh Nate Ruffin from We Are
Marshall because he was such a cool hip
cat fantastic thank you yes please
sister chuckling here in the front row
as well we can just get the microphone
right we're gonna stand the front row
for the next couple questions and move
back congratu Oh yep your red cursor
microphone cue the geek with a Captain
America t-shirt
oh I've got awesome film guys I think
you guys are fantastic
from the heart feel amazing um it's a
weird because I love all your work
individually genuinely not being a
suffering that um in terms of the
question yes oh yeah get to the boy
Captain America is obviously a simple
the characters are really I think
Erskine in the first film says he's a
good man we want to show use a good man
I was actually genuinely touched as cool
as that sounds I think the whole Steve's
journey both in the first film in this
film but obviously the world is a lot
grittier now and the characters nor the
espionage and stuff like that how did
you maintain the essence of what as
consider Captain America's a good man in
this world is a bit darker characters
that obviously a bit Shady
how did you without being corny how did
you keep that at the core and also the
other acted around it how were you able
to kind of what bounce off that and were
you inspired a bit by the character as
well well I mean actual question he just
is a good man I mean it's it's about you
know developing a character and
hopefully if you develop a I don't think
the part of him that is a good man is
necessarily dependent upon his
environment he's a good man
essentially in a vacuum he's just a good
person he doesn't bleed on people he's
he has morals and values and hopefully
if you put him anywhere
whether it's in 40s or modern era or
whether it's a you know period film or a
grittier political thriller hopefully
the the qualities of who he is will
still shine through
in terms of not making it corny I think
that's more of a director question mm oh
I would say I mean look I think it's
also I mean look at not making him corny
yeah you cast Chris Evans right so he I
mean Chris has this great you know he's
able to balance the character in a way
that's always Joe and I have always been
by its really he sort of he strikes the
balance between sort of somebody who's
like self-confident and and focused and
he could put the emphasis on that I
think the rather than on righteousness
you know which is important but for us I
mean look we we always let we we we
always like the more complicated version
of the character the sort of simple
version of the character was never that
appealing to us so you know we we tried
to put him in a very complex situation
and play to the complexities I mean he
starts the movie off in a very
vulnerable place this is the the first
movie where we really catch up to him in
modern day and see what it means to him
on a character level to have missed 70
years and woken up and found that nobody
from his old life is around anymore it's
a very isolated place very emotionally
vulnerable place so his relationships to
the other characters in the movie are
even more important because he has
nobody so I think that's that's
basically how we kept them grounded how
we approach the character obviously one
of the key components of the black widow
character is this enigmatic past which
is still affecting and defining her and
but it seems at the end of this movie
Alicia's perhaps a little more receptive
to maybe people known a bit more on that
entails so would you as an actress be
interested in going there and exploring
that and realizing that film or do you
think perhaps some things about left
undefined and it crush up the character
of some of her intriguing history
um well you'll get more of widows
backstory in Avengers 2 also really yeah
um and and I think her backstories I
mean she has a rich rich past as you
just you know already described she's um
she definitely comes from a really dark
past um you know I think she's kind of
had to be sort of she's had to sort of D
sensitize or de putte minions in a way
to be able to do and see some of the
things that she's you know I'm seen and
participated in willingly and they
probably most people that have that kind
of job
um description you know a mercenary they
do um but I think she's just sort of now
grappling with the fact that she may be
experiencing some trauma from that or at
least that she has feelings about the
things that that she's might maybe she
doesn't sleep so well at night and and
you know it's just sort of hitting her
now that she's kind of been you know
acting as a sort of um you know gun for
hire and you know that in doing that
she's never really made any active
choices and that kind of it's sort of
like the rug has been she's kind of
pulled from under her feet so I think
more interestingly what would probably
be to discover her you know to follow
the progression of that story and you
know bring her back home or see where
that see where that kind of leads to but
of course you know that's all in my
imaginary yeah next installment you know
none of that's really been you know
we've thrown a ball around a little bit
but um nothing is in the works right now
for that in this film your character has
slightly more dramatic meat than it's
had perhaps in the other Marvel films
that perhaps be a bit more to like the
humor that you bring whereas this one as
a more serious tone to your performance
and wondered how that gets your
experience when we're not seeing this
feel particularly compared to the others
um I approach you all of it you know the
same way you all show up you look at the
relationships what's going on
take it all seriously and still have as
much fun as you can on the inside of it
I'm really glad that we saw more of Nick
and what happens with him and
you know how he reacts to situations but
as usual you know he's always trying to
be three steps ahead and all of a sudden
when he finds out you know he's been
used in another kind of way incumbent
upon him to find out why and use all the
tools that he has at his disposal to
make that happen
and as usual and part of it has to do
with subterfuge and and diversion even
down to fooling and hurting his most
trusted compete reott and we actually
shot a scene where that's explained or
we have that moment but I've been told
it slows the film down in a significant
way and I didn't want to slow down but
when you get the DVD and you click on my
face there's a hidden feature that will
allow you to access that scene and
you'll see more of what that means
between he and Black Widow but it was
real joy to be able to go into Nick's
workplace and to find out who he is and
depth in certain ways and to expose some
of the stuff through conversations that
are Robert Redford and I and the film
Anthony and Joe as Destroyers are a lot
of stuff in the cutting room floor can
we expect a lot of extra scenes in the
DVD and blu-ray we we actually were
fortunate to have a lot of time to work
on the script and prep the movie and
prior to execution
so think I think it's about six or seven
minutes of deleted scenes okay not not
not a particularly large amount it used
to be that for the films were very much
standalone and the one thing Marvel has
done fantastically well as actors and
writers and directors is create that
universe I'm wondering is does that
affect the approach to make in the movie
when you haven't just got one story to
tell you've got a piece to tell you're
already funny you know got up against
Patton in two years that does there have
to be a longer longer game as it were in
the
you approach it it will it is and it is
a giant mosaic and it's a very ambitious
undertaking it's probably as ambitious
as movies have ever gotten just in terms
of the scale on the amount of films that
they're making that are interconnected
but the real secret sauce to that is
Kevin Feige of Marvel who is this tour
producer it's quite brilliant at what he
does in terms of you know keeping that
interconnectedness but also focusing on
the movie at hand you know he's very
he's very good about not putting any
constraints on the film that he's
working on because you know he has the
the belief that you know if you're
thinking about the future then you're
not going to make the best movie that
you can right now so he really tries to
make the best film that he can and then
figure out what the next movie is going
to be beyond that so very organic
process there's a lot of physical action
going on in this film amidst all the
other stuff what was the biggest
challenge for you guys were there any
injuries
I mean there's always there are always
injuries E but whether you're whether
you end up in a cast or not doing stunt
work it's it's physical stuff and even
when you block a punch that that punch
lands somewhere so you're always going
on with bumps and bruises and we're all
getting older and so it has it has
lasting effects anything in particular
um yeah
any fight with Frank Grillo yeah gotta
know how to pull his punches Mac you
must know this now we were hitting each
other for real for real if you don't
block Frank Grillo's punch you're gonna
get knocked that's cuz he's an actual
box he's a very nice doesn't know
anything about 100 that's because he's a
mean person yeah so I'll do the same
thing Nic Cage the other night
frank grillo beat the [ __ ] didn't um
today I mean if I'm forever wounded
I'm from these movies I know I know I
mean I have old injuries from Iron Man
two days and I just keep reordering them
that's part of the that's part of the
joy that's not part of the joy the
process I guess I mean like Chris said
it gets you know you as you sustained
more injuries over time and it hurts for
longer and things like that but um I
don't know it's uh I guess I like to be
able to do as much of the stunt work as
possible
and I don't you know I think you take
her a little bit of a risk with that but
uh I'd rather I'd rather that than you
know have to hand off my scenes to the
stunt team that's capable and amazing as
they are all the time I'd rather do some
of it you know and have some battle
wounds that way I could compare bruises
and the assignment Sebastian any
injuries I mean you know I feel like I
got pretty familiar with Chris's kneecap
like once or twice I don't know that we
were doing everything so quickly and and
we sort of prepare for months doing
those fight sequences so I honestly
wouldn't feel anything until I was on in
the car on the way home when I couldn't
get out of the seat like being dropped
off at the hotel but I'm sure we heard
each other you didn't hurt me you I
haven't burst time I'm seeing you that's
why I say quite used to work with you
okay thank you
and and Sam you weren't on the end of a
frank grillo punch at any point but hey
yeah did you get any injuries on yeah no
I just messed up man extensively
I have no issues with him being hurt
that's what he paid to do and he loves
it he from a stunt family his father was
a stunt man all of his brothers are
stuck man before they could eat
breakfast in the morning and dad kicked
him down the stairs in the one I made
him jump out a window to come downstairs
to get their breakfast so I used kiante
more than my god he works more than I do
sometimes why didn't I learn that I'm
Sony movie every time I'm coming limping
and I'm like iron so bad it seems like
why don't you let other people that are
better is done it's way better to you
know see him you know you you stand
there they throw a punch you duck out of
the way they fight and you get up and go
and run off and do the next guy that's
not simple it's good for you Scarlett
Johansson Captain America has his shield
and Falcon can fly you only have two
small girls have you ever asked for
anything more to protect yourself as
effects in the film and the second
question is do how do you identify with
Black Widow well I have a bite I have a
widow's bite and uh you know all kinds
of things that come out of my IVA belt
it's multi-purpose um and I have my wit
of course my sensational wit um my kung
fu like wit and I I don't know I mean I
I'm I think part of the widow's fighting
style and what makes her sort of
charming is that she uses her size
against you know her opponent and kind
of it's to her advantage that she's
fighting these big dudes and she's this
kind of quick and quick thinking you
know click on her feet kind of houses
are now it's hard to catch yeah you
can't teach quick love that yeah Jenna
yeah and and I mean I think that the the
I I like I think that I I don't know
necessarily how do I identify with her
wall I mean I think any character that
you play you have to be um
pathetic towards of course because you
know even if it's if that's a villainous
character um that's what makes you sort
of I always have to have that bit of
likability to you um I think this
character has a certain unexpected
humility to her that's kind of she's
that soft underbelly and none and I have
that theme song not that you do that you
do it question for mr. Jackson oh I was
wondering as a fully paid-up member of
the Association of spectacles where else
how you call within the wearing of the
eyepatch in these movies because no
matter how good one is when one eye
other eye is closed it must affect
peripheral vision and may mean you bump
into other actors and to scenery stuff
like that or mr. an advise ditch does
wearing the patch improve your potty um
you know I can deter my head further
actually just like you know doing that
but the interesting thing about the
patches that I didn't discover until
Captain America on the first one was
because I never had very many lines to
say when I all of a sudden had dialogues
and I would learn it the night before
when I got to work I can only see half
the page when I sew I've discovered that
I have to actually learn my lines now
when one hand covering my eyes so that
my mind will absorb what's going on in
there and that's the one thing but I put
with both my eyes open don't you oh oh
well see yeah yeah do I want to work on
that though Scarlett you are a musician
as well as an actress I was wondering if
the rest of you have any hidden music
ability and if you'd want to do
capturing every school should be albums
this year would you play the harpsichord
interest which we saw she saw Anthony do
any musical abilities to playing
instruments you play Bailey oh man ah
you lose heart
okay I get I can deal with the trumpet a
little bit I you know growing up in the
wall and you have to learn answer me so
I could deal with the trumpet I'm nice
on the spoons yeah I could do a funky
beat you know oh [ __ ] oh this is some
turntables you know okay
well in other words no Sebastian any
musical talent in there nope no musical
talent just good ol karaoke you know
okay you know that's that's all I got
which we're doing tonight at you're
doing Chester Simon yeah I play this to
miss when I was a kid yeah I played
French horn and flute and I've learned
to play various instruments for
different films like guitar piano cello
but I don't hold I don't keep up okay
all right Chris oh yeah I put the piano
on the guitar not the same time surely
no at the same time it's it's quite a
time Z it's really good so Anthony and
Joey I can expect Captain America 3 will
be a musical then captain yeah
exclamation why dad right okay we're
gonna presents doing solo might as well
on everyone's already said this but
finger films fantastic that's the best
mom film yet
guess what ask you see it's our
questions access for Sebastian you
previously said you've got a nine
picture contract with Marvel day that's
what happened to the rest of my DS
exactly
okay you know where for karaoke kitschy
cost missing your character becoming
Captain America in the future I hope so
and now movies yeah I have no idea man I
I mean I really I really don't know I'm
still like trying to you know realize
that I'm sitting up here with these guys
you know so I'm wherever those two
fellas
want to take you know the the stories
where I'm going so and also thank you
just cut me out well we were going to
use this press conference Ashley to
announce that Anthony Mack will no
longer be with forward Falcon what
Falcon was a one-off Iron Fist is taking
over fact America free is going to go
against Batman and Superman you may have
the girl fans to sue to beat up the ante
and do you think you might see another
Avenger celebrity boxing match that's
what yeah we're working right now uh no
I don't know I think who said this best
that you know when two two cars are
speeding at each other one of them has
got to veer out of what out of the way
at some point so hey oh yeah put it out
there baby boy tell him tonight
tell them the listen I think you know
Marvel Marvel I think announce that date
originally it was a if you go back
historically and look at it Marvel and I
think Sony been trading off and that may
date for a long time and I think when
Warner Brothers decided to move that
film they moved it to the may date so
you know I can see where Kevin said one
I'm not moving off at all so yeah it's
right over there so I don't think
there'll be anything to up the ante
other than that you know hopefully we
make a great movie and everybody's very
excited to see it on was it may 5th or
may 6th and I mean that's the truth is
anybody up anybody up here is just all
we can do is make a
focus on making the best movie we can
make and when and how it gets released
is you know there's other forces
involved in that in other words in other
words punk step up to get me down oh my
god how about that Marvel we're heroes
yeah there's DC where you have
interesting bad guys we got Chris Evans
baby deal with dad it's all kicking I've
got a question from my six-year-old son
Collins to everybody
basically the Avengers obviously are his
heroes who is your hero that's his
question to everybody
oh yeah it's Goodwin like our life hero
or like a superhero hero a life sure
I'll say my I mean is so generic but
I'll say my parents I mean they're
they're they're your first
they're the ones who shape you and make
you and teach you how to love and how to
feel pain and happiness and cope and
it's it's everything from the you know
from birth until you're you know in your
teen years that's what you're really
forming who you are and I really got to
tip my hat to my parents they're my
heroes good luck everyone else following
that's my samuel l.jackson thank you Sam
I look at the young people that you know
put their lives on the line for us so
that we do have you know the freedom to
make movies like this and tell stories
like this because I mean we do have a
volunteer army now it's not like people
have to do it
ah and those young men and women that go
out there and put their lives on the
line and go to different countries and
just they're there you know to make sure
that we can do what we do
I admire him greatly okay
and uh yeah indeed and Sebastian
well my mom definitely uh and I guess
probably Jim Carrey yeah yeah yeah
I don't know I I was obsessed with Jim
Carrey growing up so led me to acting I
guess and an Anthony uh my two brothers
don't say mr. Marcus no man my two
brothers I mean I spent the first 12
years of my life with him beating me up
and the past 32 years and 22 years of my
life with them applaud me and building
me up so my two brothers fantastic and
and Joe you haven't mentioned a hero yet
I can't decide if it's Superman or
Batman maybe if maybe if somebody made a
film where they put them both in that
movie together yeah
you